welcome everyone to another episode of
Red Cafe live right here at animal per
episode 38 today and this week we're
discussing the biggest anime letdowns
here with me today so far just anime
recon what he has become the most
dependable you can always depend on the
Recon me talking to myself
good work recon glad to have you here
well all I can say is now always the
person I'm most likely the always the
first person who arrives when you say
because I'm always on time I'm a
schedule person yeah you're a great guy
and I know you like to get triggered and
it makes for great drama entertainment
so that's why we love you we should be
getting some more people joining us in a
minute
raucous so we'll stay tuned for that but
in the meantime for today's topic I just
want to make sure that what we're gonna
tell is the biggest animal letdowns but
this can include anything it can include
anime that weren't renewed for a second
season or something that happened in an
anime that was really disappointing or a
bad adaptation of anime to manga
anything is open game so let us know
everyone in the child welcome I see a
bunch of people in there
let us know what some of your biggest
enemy let downs disappointments were and
we'll take it from there soul are you
here with us I'm here we're seeing his
face for the first time no not for the
first time but yeah not really soul has
shown his face many times on his to face
for a while well this isn't his true
face yeah whereas many mask seems like
God you know no one from Game of Thrones
yeah yeah yeah I have no one and I know
that soul is ready for this discussion
because as soon as I said let's do the
biggest anime let down is calm man don't
get me started
I've got a few in mind yeah I mean I
mean there's a lot of like I gotta go
adapted like never got adapted well or
you know just I never got completed
properly
stuff you know I mean everyone's got
that animate that they watch they're
like where season 2 where season free
you know so yeah I mean that's money
that's money yeah very very true
we got people mention Guilty Crown
already we have Mac Alfie says I was
disappointed by the time time see what
what attacked in season 2 was amazing
bros good also
Light Yagami end of Light Yagami in
death notice being mentioned I can
definitely relate to that I know some
people don't like light but I definitely
thought that he would end up you know on
top at the end so that was weird that
was disappointing also a snow early mob
boss nearly what's up man he says that
one of the biggest disappointments was
when anime recon became an Sao fanboy
[ __ ] you I just know that you guys are
gonna talk about Sao the a low mortgage
[ __ ] well guess what the Recon fans
don't care what other people say cuz I'm
a true Sao fanboy and I'm the only harem
alien one thing I do respect about recon
is that he looks up to a character like
a Tito who is not a crybaby yeah that's
a good thing like Rika could be looking
up to like Shinji or Renton Thurston
frog Erica 7 but instead at least he
looks up to an Opie you know guy who
gets the girls and stuff so I respect
that at least he recognizes himself and
in in someone like that so I like that
recon thank you yeah see you sometimes I
compliment you man by the way I just
want to say that for the last six Ranke
phase we got over 2,000 views overall
which is awesome when we first started
these things streams always get less
views in normal videos and when we first
started using these things we've got
like a few hundred views so the fact
that we are growing the rank of an
audience is awesome thank you all for
watching would really appreciate that
drop a like if you do enjoy these and
also I'm going to wake you guys in the
comments so once this
stream is uploaded in the comments give
us suggestions for future weeks themes
if you have some ideas for what you want
us to discuss in future weeks so topics
for rent cafes well not in the chat
necessarily because that's going to be
erased but once the video is uploaded
then giving it to us in the comments
that are gonna stay there so that I can
look through them later on and we can
decide which topics we like the most Sao
season 2 was a big disappointment
although Luna says that Sao is awesome
so Luna is on your side
recon that's good but I don't know why
season 2 is a letdown for people I mean
it's GGO foods guns in action I mean I
enjoyed it at least I don't know why
many people say it's a letdown snoring
I'm not sure what you mean by fake
account there Josh Bowman what's up man
Josh Bowman always supporting anime
opera appreciate that man I think he
means the Animax thing count that you
talked about it I think yesterday I'm
like oh yeah so there was something some
people we're using a fake anime up or
account to comment on other people's
videos and post links including the
anime man's video so I tweeted about
that guys
like if you check that account you see
it has 0 subs it's a fake account it's
someone who's just trying to make us
look bad or something I don't know but
Joey knows that's not us so don't worry
about that the real enemy offer does not
post links and other people's videos
alright it's not Adam rest assured I'll
see there is there is a few people were
saying to like si oh man in the chat you
coming you know they're able to admit
that they like SEO because of Eureka
because it is nice to have people on my
side for a change I mean all the haters
it's all so publicly defended Sao people
were like no one wanted to defend it but
then when recon came out out of the SAO
closet if you will and people were like
man this guy's brave I'm with them I'm
with him yeah also I saw I saw who does
Jonathan Essex has been here
amen tolya what's up
grim axe and something interesting
earlier that I forgot what I was sorry
that I have no respect for Toya what are
some of your recon your disappointments
that you can think of the time whether
or not getting another season or a bad
adaptation for the first one that came
to my head would be high school the dead
oh well it disappointed me I mean I
loved it it didn't get a second season
because an earthquake happened and all
the stuff so many problems and then we
note and then a few day a few years or
months later then we know that the
author has died and yeah that's
basically the end of high school of the
dead it's not gonna have it the second
season any time and it's a bigger
letdown for a lot of people who were
expecting a second season so much about
that no anymore
yeah that's the only one that I would
bring up i schooled the dead also
dramatic degree but Black Butler one
isn't much better August I'll tell you
that much I only watch that show because
I like the Victorian feel and less so I
was like at one point I was as I was
writing a book about Victorian style
steampunk genre novel so I was watching
a lot of steampunk anime and Victorian
style animation that's why I watched it
but throughout the whole thing I was
coming not a anime recommend 21
personally not my style
but it looks like NOK stock who is in
the building
Knox are you here uh I am I don't know
if you can hear me my thing is going
that's a little yeah I hear you know I
hear you loud and clear
great yeah Salman good as always
how you been Knox did not explain away
just came finished or takusan which is a
big con in mocha and Quebec they gained
a minute not so how was that that was
great
got to chill with misty a little bumped
in tark ADA Washburn extra and are
caught up yeah cool guys cool Canadian
yeah
well that's mostly it I want a
competition but no one cares about that
what did you a trivia they show a line
from an anime on the screen and you have
to guess which character from which
animates from oh they didn't they have
taste come on it begins ok here we go
again a neogeo mentioned the iron blood
endorphins comparing it to the onion art
- yes iron blood ruins biggest
disappointment possibly in the history
of anime the ending of iron blooded
orphans yeah that was a terrible angry
terrible ending I don't care I know
people defend it no no it wasn't
realistic
it wasn't good storytelling it was a
terrible [ __ ] ending in the worst way
and I hated it hated it no I just hated
the fact that he got killed by the girl
that's so not so your disappointments
father does SEO I wouldn't call a
disappointment it was more of an
expectation I saw her was going already
from the beginning right recon thank you
but as far as disappointments you
mentioned Guilty Crown anyone watch
guilty crown
yes yeah yeah I dropped it within like
five six episodes I was just like no no
okay well then no disappointing for you
I mean I enjoyed it I watched it all the
way through I mean it was alright what
the greatest thing I've ever seen I
don't know I just didn't like it I
didn't like the way it was so I don't
like the way it felt
I was just that not although just
thinking about it now I think my biggest
disappointment ever is log horizon
season 2 season 1 was amazing I loved it
Shiro it was my first profile picture
YouTube then season 2 came out and I
changed it right away
it got licensed by a different studio
and they destroyed it and what happened
in 20 what happened in 25 episodes in
the second season would have taken four
episodes in the first season the writing
was worse the animation was worse did
anyone watch it I've watched it all yeah
and you like you liked the second season
not as good as the first one by I agree
with your points there well I didn't
know it was actually animated by a
different studio who animated the first
one again uh I think it was Dean but I
have to check your Dean yesterday / Dean
is good I don't know who [ __ ] up the
second one though might be stinger I got
ya
oh speaking of Studio Pierrot um Tokyo
ghoul season 2 was horrible I mean the
first season wasn't it was not my
favorite anime of all time
Tokyo girls first season but season 2
was just abysmal like wow Naruto's
Tokugawa Sega
yep sure hyped up show before I watched
it Aaron was like you gotta watch us I
watched it I couldn't even get through
the first like five episodes so it was I
really didn't like the first season
either people said the second season
with a big disappointment people said
that in general it was badly adapted
from the manga which is something I know
Seoul wants to speak to but yeah like to
me Tokyo ghoul huge disappointment I
know a lot of people thought that the
season 2 was a huge disappointment so
I'll bring that to you a bit and you can
touch on the whole adaptation stuff that
I know you're itching to talk about yeah
okay yeah I mean there's a lot out there
there's too many to count really big
ones that really annoyed me though was
Rosario cross vampire which going by the
anime to see we just felt like ecchi
harem well like a satchel manga was
totally different it was more like a
battle Shonen the main character rather
than being like a useless no one this
instantly protected by girls actually
becomes like really powerful and he
actually fights alongside them and stuff
then there's the dancing the vampire
bond which basically only touches the
tip of the iceberg of the story which is
it's only about I think 12 episodes long
the season and that's it there's no
continuation or nothing so you know that
was quite upsetting there's also cold
breakers which everyone I know that is
where the manga says that the anime was
just not as good same like the Twin Star
Exorcist anime as well I don't know what
it is about the Twin Star Exorcist anime
though cuz I can't put my finger on it
it's just it just feels like there's
something missing compared to when you
read the manga it's just I couldn't get
through four episodes of twin star
Exorcist anime but my brother watched it
and he said you have to you have to try
it it's amazing shown and whatever so I
read the manga and I also I enjoyed the
manga yeah but then when you when you're
watching the anime is just like I don't
know I'll dish yeah and yeah Fox
the manga is people were telling me no
he's in the manga yeah but he shows up
way later in the manga yeah not such a
major role he's not just there to sell
plushies yeah yeah basically yeah yeah
definitely
yeah there's loads of them
yeah original ink says almost every
live-action adaptation of anime ever
that's a good point definitely solid
yeah as well as many 3d anime like
berserk died oh don't don't have me
please that's that Jesus Christ that's
terrible yeah that's so like a soft spot
and the manga as well if I'm not
mistaken yeah definitely I love um what
else was I gonna talk about yeah I feel
like lightening darkness is trolling me
because he wanted me to talk about Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood at one punch
man neither of those work in any way a
disappointment to me
so I don't know if you're just trolling
me man I don't know what's going on but
absolutely not I love those for me I
would say a what I no Seraph was also a
disappointment I agree with you I liked
the first game
yeah but it was sort of a disappointment
after episode 1 episode 1 was great and
then it just do not really for me season
1 was good season 2 was also good but
C's episode ones
yeah season there was no season 3 sorry
did not add a season 3 season
- sorry season 2 was a little bit of a
disappointment because in the very very
end of season 2 they left off at a
cliffhanger and put themselves on a
season we're just not gonna happen at
all well once you're mentioning which
studio which studio has one type of
anime they put out attack on Titan and I
got really hyped and everything was
great and then they puts her at the end
and cabin area the iron fortress and
both of them have the exact same
storyline just worse commentary is
getting the season - yeah yeah yeah but
they all have the first episode
humanity is in need and is in you know
despair and stuff it's up to one boy to
save the day pretty sure that's what
study was mostly famous for hero to save
the day ya know but wood carbon every
door it's not just the one boy is it
yeah I mean it's like I mean really it's
the girl and it's Toma more than
whatever in a mume yeah he does more he
does much more especially at the end she
goes berserk sort of no and he saves the
day looking at okay if you're looking at
Eren and Mikasa Eren is not the only
character either an attack on Titan but
it mainly focuses on that one boy that
will pull humanity forward damn to
destroy all damn you all who say me cuz
I saw
yes people in the chat I am wearing our
Columbia Jersey because it's a great
colors it's a quality Jersey you support
a good home Interac
um someone said something here that I
wanted to show up on oh yeah
attack on Titan someone mentioned that
there there's going to be an anime about
Annie and mica so yeah there is this is
gonna be is it's going to be will talk
about in the next weekly video but what
its gonna weekly anime news casts know
what its gonna be is a OVA sort of few
episodes I think three and it's gonna
cover the spin-off manga because there
is a spin-off manga of attack on Titan
called Lost Girls that looks at Mikasa
and Annie however I don't even think
that stuff is canon like it's very it's
very weird side stories they're not
necessarily connected to the main
storyline at all but if money goes manga
any time and kind of check it out for
yourself what its gonna cover but yeah
it's not it's not like a huge reveal
it's not gonna be you know anything too
pertinent to the main storyline so I
will caution you about that did you
mention Death Note yeah wait light ended
up however I saw someone else in the
John mentioned what happens to L was a
huge disappointment and I agree as well
L such a great character there's so many
people that I talk to that watch death
no were so disappointed what happens to
pal
although on the one hand I respect the
creators of Death Note for taking such a
huge step knowing how popular both of
these characters were because it was
like it was unpredictable it was like a
game of Thrones type twist but in the
end you know everyone loved L so it is
definitely a big letdown for people
honestly if the anime would have ended
at episode 25 I wouldn't have been upset
either way either way I would've been
fine you know sometimes the bad guys win
also I mean I don't mind if light wins
but you know they just need it to
somehow end things off in 12 episodes so
they came up with near and Mello and
just uh I don't know not it spiraled out
for those 12 episodes well I mean to be
fair its how the manga was so well
not every manga is perfect yeah no
definitely not look at Naruto and bleach
yeah okay Naruto and bleach the last arc
in both of them were a letdown yeah yeah
each was mentioned in the China's world
a bleach manga so yeah that's a good one
yeah I mean that's more than just that
was a letdown cuz like I think the first
biggest letdown for Bleach was the full
moon saga that's where a lot of the
community were complaining they were
just like yeah you know this this arc is
just stupid ichigo's crying again you
know what's going on and then yeah with
the route oh Jesus Christ I think
everything after pain yeah I like the
five Kage summit honestly I did but I
didn't like the war I think that there
are so many things that everyone could
have done differently by the time the
war came along it was just which ninja
could fart out a bigger jutsu and that
was basically the rest of the story I
mean there was no strategy on either
sides cuz you don't have strategy when
you have these explosions as it is and
that was one of my favorite parts of
Naruto like one of my favorite of the
early fights was Shikamaru versus tamari
it was like there was no action in that
fight it was all thinking on both sides
and that was a great you know ninja type
fight yeah I've seen more of Shikamaru
like when he went up against the
immortal duo hit down kakuzu that was
awesome that was great was that was
great that was probably my favorite arc
of Shahbuddin yeah yeah but then yeah I
would love to see more of that you know
yeah but then you know can I ask you a
question
you know deidara has his ultimate art
that one massive explosion yeah the c2c
whatever whatever it's got c4 probably
whatever it's called anyway so you know
how they do ten side guys can regenerate
so why didn't he fly into you know good
guy HQ ultimate art kaboom everyone's
dead
he'll regenerate and blow up more yeah
he could have spun there are so many
things that could have been done that
warrants because we already saw that
character when he was alive so we don't
need to use him so well when he's dead
already
exactly
no the what no the worst oh my god the
biggest letdown was Kakashi against the
seven swordsmen yeah panel like we
didn't even see the fight you know we
see him take out the same guy he took
out before Zabuza and Haku and then as
the the other swordsmen there we go away
anime the anime leg in the anime they
had a whole arc of killing those sword
been all filler and it was terrible like
cuz I already read food my god didn't I
don't blame you once I got through that
ninja ostrich filler how is it for the
anime that's another disappointment all
the bloody fillers yeah oh my gosh you
guys really went full Naruto it's just
we have knowledge these'll don't let me
just say cat gamer was asking if I saw
the top 100 anime in the 100 years of
anime list and I did I watched Joey the
anime mates video and the time you asked
if I got triggered I mean not really
yeah I thought that some great anime
were a rank 2 Lord and they should be in
some crappy anime or not but it was a
popularity quiz like it wasn't like what
is the greatest anime quality-wise it
was like what is the most popular anime
so of course as you know as course love
life would be in that number 3 most
quality ones the two things I was
happiest to see on that list was Code
Geass number 7 that was nice to see and
sorted on line number 20
that was awesome I don't care attack on
Titan was like 25 Death Note wasn't even
on the list yeah that was weird
oh it's better than attack on Titan
confirm you guys get what I mean
number 20 don't make jokes man I know
your I know your dorky but no I'm not
joking that's what's been confirmed by
the anime men
if anyone plans not confirmed I urge you
see now a letdown for me was Soul Eater
in you seer was good but the I agree we
all agree on that everyone you saw
agrees yeah I mentioned Overlord in a
previous video first three episodes good
the rest was terrible you gave me some
time thank you for to tell me think
about why I really didn't like Ines so I
I think I can quantify it in recon terms
let's take let's take Kirito yeah does
everyone like does everyone like Kirito
me i don't i personally don't dislike
him okay so you like him I just don't
think like he was pretty bland but Ines
is way more overpowered than Kirito and
you give an explanation why he's more
overpowered but just because there's a
reason why someone is crazy strong that
doesn't meet that doesn't make the show
good just because it makes sense that
he's powerful like I can explain I can
think that overlord is good yeah but I
still I can explain to you why Kirito is
is as powerful as he is it makes sense
if you think about it I mean I in in in
a sentence
grinding gets you stronger faster and he
was a solo player because he watched the
blackcats all die in episode 3 and he
was like no I'm just gonna be the
strongest and I'm gonna grind he sat
there and he just grinded and grinded
and grinded and that was it and if you
play pokemon and you just sit there you
know with the vs seeker and the grass or
whatever and you just keep grinding
you're gonna beat everyone because
that's
does that makes order online a great
anime because it makes sense sort of yqd
toes overpowered yes okay and I think
overlord is way over hyped so my hyped I
don't see anyone hyping it up like you
so it's the best thing ever
yeah I mean I don't I don't see that so
no came out on you when overloaded
bridge came out on YouTube it got like
600,000 views in a week
that's hype sao bridge then what did
that get yeah a lot of you that has like
8 million views and that was really well
done and sorta online has hype and no
one disagrees with that by the way my
son asked in the chat oh I didn't notice
him I didn't notice you saying anything
earlier if I thought that's why I didn't
notice you my man won one disappointment
I think a lot of you guys can agree with
me on and if you do let me know in the
chat is that the devil is a part-timer
didn't get a season two
I'm with you yeah 100%
yeah that needed a sequel yeah that was
a hilarious hilarious comedy anime
really like how they switched it up from
like a dark fantasy to just like a slice
of life comedy and yeah I really enjoyed
it quite a bit so I was very
disappointed cuz it seemed quite popular
too
and so it was it and got to Netflix
right away for Netflix before Netflix
was evil hey got there immediately
here's what I'm gonna say one of the
newest enemy that is currently airing
that was looking so forward to buzz
disappointed me
misuk I was smartphone and actually Toya
is in the chat right now a Toya make
yourself less [ __ ] Opie man are you
are you saying how are you animating
needs to be less OB men like I just what
do you understand that this guy is a
character clone I know he's a character
clone and that's why I don't like it it
tries to copy Conan Suba
and Kira in the Toya's to Opie the
series it's a guilty pleasure I never
had any hope for that series I would
only get disappointed if I had hope for
something and was let down no I don't
know anything in that I had high hopes
for that I thought would be good but nah
I just yeah I mean don't say so as far
as this season fate Apocrypha is a bit
of a letdown for me I was really excited
for that I'm liking it
I've only seen the format but definitely
disappointed with all the lollies like
over the top Jack the Ripper just like
just like act this tripper
catering you know pandering to fans with
all the lollies of traps and [ __ ] like I
hate that type of stuff yeah angry like
comparin tree compared fate/zero
to fade apocryphally fate/zero is like
the most perfect anime fight me what no
zero is perfection oh it's good always
good place not perfection come on I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of
problems with it coming I don't know I
was up there with Hunter hunter in Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood wise either
why what why is he there why is who
where why subbu death subaru subaru on
and fate/zero fate/zero oh no no face
you oh no no face zero has good moments
in it yeah but it's not it's not a good
story so I know a great story no it's
not good stay all right that's it for
another stream well fade zero something
better than re0 my friend no way no one
chance not a chance
yeah no is greatness yeah it's good it's
okay it's not greatness yeah vormax man
don't don't say [ __ ] like cannot ending
was bad tonight I think was perfect and
amazing and you're just making me want
to make that video about it but I don't
have
I'll freakin trigger me quite deduction
well it's like this just cuz you don't
understand some doesn't make it bad yeah
but a lot of times people don't know
that they don't understand something
okay thinking of don't know they don't
understand did anyone watch serial
experiments lain yes yeah I hated it
yeah cuz you didn't get it they did I
got it I got it at least I think I got
it
it's like it's trying to make believe
it's so deep when it's so not it's so
shallow and it's just total the wired is
so weird cuz sounds like wired and weird
or spelled similarly that was like the
show okay yeah but I I get into
arguments on this all the time so yeah
also god is awesome from that is awesome
dramatic you're wrong you are
objectively wrong objectively wrong my
friend that's it that's it repent repent
for your wrongness most anime that go
off the manga at the end like blue
exorcist or Claymore all that you know
is disappointing yeah yeah Claymore had
a lot of potential and then they just
sound like the one season went off the
rails from the manga and then they never
continued it but I felt that was one of
those serious mature stories that had
potential even though the protagonist
kid was a pretty big crybaby but at
least the girl is also a protagonist and
she is not choose about us so because
that I could like enjoy that anime but
if it was just officially and in the
manga the crybaby guy somehow gets
somewhere
Seoul was telling me yeah I baby forever
laughter what he goes when they separate
in it he ends up training with Isley
king of the north yeah then after
training with him for years
he then ends up getting caught in the
middle of this battle where he ends up
getting like infected so then he becomes
like hey halfway I kind of guy
and then from there you know he's then
fighting alongside some claim walls so
can I say how to mitten oh god no it's
not I'm not gonna say it's a big letdown
but there's something in the series as a
big letdown
which is censorship yes you just don't
know the right side you are done go go
anime no I've watched on crunchyroll as
the cultural subscription and then when
like the hand of God appears I have to
go on to mine anime to watch it isn't is
the censorship not part of the enemy is
it added later no no if you buy the
blu-ray you won't have it yeah but uh
it's mostly disappointing in the series
is the [ __ ] fat guy again in episode
5 yes get you stood it's gonna be a
one-liner in every episode in the newest
episode he [ __ ] maps out every kid in
town on the piece of paper and he
[ __ ] stalks them I'm not up to date
I'm not even joking Anna Mac it's not
funny anymore
it's pissing me off yeah it's not funny
that's like that guy's a [ __ ] serial
killer does he like it's a piece of
paper he goes around town he maps out
where every little kid lives so he can
stalk them in the night and probably
kidnap them I don't know man okay see
this is the thing that shows funny
moments i watch the first few episodes
but now like hearing that [ __ ] i don't
want to watch it because like i would
rather watch [ __ ] a guru ii that would
make me feel less uncomfortable than
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] like that's saying
something
oh it really is annoying any of you
watch world world trigger yes so I think
that had a really great story it was a
little slow because toy animation knows
how to make things slow and I think that
it was a letdown that it never continued
I think it could have been should have
and I really
liked it no one here else watched will
trigger maka no idea oh man oh sorry bro
mami I in terms of like animator
probably no one watched Last Exile is an
enemy I watched it was pretty big
disappointment it had a lot of potential
but the pacing was very bad and the same
thing with a winetka 7 nice world
building interesting concept but pacing
just terrible terrible pacing cool
characters squandered because they were
never developed so yeah that anime was a
huge disappointment for me especially
since I knew all these fanboys just
maddening people why oh you got a you
got a good and the fake enemy I just you
guys were talking with the whole Lalique
on stuff in hajimeta nogal i came up
with a new term not lolly calm no Lacan
no that is my term because I am no not
interested in that yet yeah asan
mentions fun and working for the fandom
and I have to say the ending of that was
like well in fact it's the whole last
word of it that was really a letdown
I've shown some of the guys on discord
like I have a food stream now or just
shot him like the images it's like the
main character is like 20 in the second
part of the series and then he meets
this little girl called cow which I
don't know she's about maybe 10 maybe
I'll push and then there's a time skip
like because he fakes his death and
leaves and then when he comes back again
he's then in high school right remember
he's already 20 and now we've had a time
skip he's in high school and cow look
girl you know little lolly girl to a
full grown woman
and somehow he's pulling off this role
as being a high school student and it
just felt so forced that setting of
having like high school there and stuff
it was just it was just so stupid
it was so stupid and then that in the
ending is oh my god he stood there in a
field with the the girl I know you get
shot in the back he falls over dead and
I turns around thinking like oh he's
just laying in the field and then she
just lays down back in the field and
then she's there just talking to him
kind of thing and it ends and it's like
wow okay yeah I'm not gonna watch this
yeah yeah but you remember erased big
sensation last year so I really liked
erased but I thought the last three
episodes were a letdown and again it
ends off with 26 I think it was 26 by
the end of the show yeah and he's like
oh that thirteen year old girl is
perfect right that's how it ended
yeah the manga the manga explained the
bear instead of you know way got his
memories back from touching the baby's
foot yeah instead of that happening
before that it wasn't the teacher who
caught the reporters it was I we that
girl that he used to work in a piece of
shop with yeah yeah she cuz remember
this is a hole in a time line now so she
don't know him so she's there she's
stopped them and stuff he's seen her
he's like some memories from his like
past time line start coming back when he
meets her and stuff then like the strain
of it causes him like to collapse but
then after when he wakes up again all
his memories have been restored and then
after he's then no it was saying the
teacher you know and then the teachers
start setting the plan in motion to kill
the little girl and pinning on him but
then he then sets up the plan with he's
doesn't detect oh no no no no it's not
to do that cuz he stuck her on his boat
and it's like got a hole so slowly
sinking in it that's how he's gonna kill
the girl so they've gone there to save
the girl he's on the bridge watching and
then our main hero he's come along to
catch him on the bridge in it
yeah I mean and then after a fires set
and stuff then end up catching him
then we get the actual like court case
you know and then after that it ends
with him like meeting up with ivy again
and stuff so yeah yeah well really
different that real either way the
relationship between him and Irie and
he's in his 20s and she's like 13 that's
weird no she was six she was sixteen in
the original timeline and at this point
Satoru was three years younger than when
the first timeline happened started with
him he was 29 and she was 16 and then he
went back and died and coma and whatever
and he woke up when he was 26 so then
she is still 13 I mean I guess so yeah
yeah that's weird
that's really weird he's literally half
his age a few people are trying to
trigger knocks in the chat by saying
that one piece was a huge disappointment
yeah Knox doesn't get triggered the
anime one piece I also think was a huge
disappointment I made enough triggering
videos to sort of develop an immunity
and I agree as far as the anime goes but
no one he reads the manga so who am I
talking to no one here is the manga
yeah that's your brother's yeah Mondays
yeah shut up now these guys just don't
read period Knox
it is subtitles is already too much of a
strain yeah much about me I try to plant
office I was driving back from New York
this week and I was really thinking
should I just stop off in the Agra Falls
see what animatics doing well it's a few
hours off yeah cuz you because you were
going from Montreal that's kind of like
further off if you were going to Buffalo
then you little bit on the way
yeah but Buffalo it there is an exit
like by Albany that goes to Buffalo yeah
yeah so that is where we are but that's
like the other end of New York State
from New York City yeah it would've been
an extra few hours yeah well get out me
if you're in town man we always love
tourists and I got Falls to take your
money and [ __ ] oh yeah
what about Boca doc you got hamachi we
were just talking about that where were
you
really um I got interrupted sorry sure
anyways forget about that done yeah
Commodore hearts patted or hearts rockin
yeah
you know that's English right hand yeah
I mean not English
it comes from Greek but it's not
Japanese yeah Fedora hearts was a
letdown especially compared to the manga
but to be fair the manga was still
ongoing when the enemy came out so they
had to make up their own kind of and
then and stuff but it is a shame that
they never got to include more of the
whole Alice in Wonderland themes the
like permeate throughout that series
like you know the Queen of Hearts and
all different things Erna
did any of you guys watch School Rumble
yeah some of it yeah two seasons in it
yeah yeah great great animate comedy
anime in terms of two
except the ending is another terrible
terrible ending yeah yeah I think he
should have went for the system and he
should he just change well I know
exactly because she was way better she
was way way and the way it ends is not
it's not suited to a comedy
light-hearted comedy anime it's just
like why like that's the one thing like
before I finished watching it people are
like man brace yourself for the ending
and I was like but it's still a funny
funny anime for sure it's just I don't
know I I don't know exactly what happens
but I know that best girl is never
picked it's like a rule across anime
yeah we mentioned Clannad before and I
don't think Nagisa was best girl at the
end of the first season of Clannad oh no
I don't know there were all better
choices pretty much yeah and what kind
of girl you like
because Nagi saw is best girl for
someone who likes a girl that depends on
them that is will do anything for them
that's the total ditz
that's a ditz and that's sickly and weak
and everything is nice and beautiful and
I don't know anyone like that um some
people like that some people like they
want to be needed they want to help a
girl they want to rescue her right they
want to be there for her and she is it
is nice that she's like positive in
spite of everything so I think she's a
very cool character but it depends some
people like assume that is like so
they'll prefer like yo right so I wasn't
a you know straight-out tsundere
that's why I liked her she never hated
in them no yeah I mean she was a little
forceful she tried to set up her sister
and she ended up liking him but yeah she
wasn't a cliched tune today I think yeah
yeah I like them too yeah yeah I agree
they were my favorites as well yeah
that's why I like D is that one episode
way is him with Tomoko instead and then
like he's coming there's one over there
OVA is with all the other endings yeah
yeah I like that one as did
not that I want to ruin after story cuz
after story was so good but yeah guys if
this video reaches 150 likes
I will go to soul Marcus house and teach
him how to pronounce Japanese names I am
gonna be making some new accounts now
hold on and I'm like I could just go to
his house for you because go recon and
tell them it's toll boyo go go slap
Funimation once you're doing it I'm
pretty sure they had it Tomoya also the
worst Ono eat up is horrible
oh god that's the worst of the biggest
trigger points of me coming to hate dubs
in general come on up well be thankful
you never heard all the big bobs of a
drug boozy they were sure ah she dub was
horrible Higurashi I prefer Dragonball
dumb I can't stand the Japanese bit
especially Goku's voice actor it's so
bad in my mind in my mind I have the
abridged series voices in my mind I'll
be honest because I I never got into
Dragonball when I was a kid so I don't
have that nostalgia factor um so yeah
for me the original Dragon Ball is the
abridged I don't know about you guys but
I've actually stopped watching the sub
of Dragon Ball super and I'm watching
the double well you beat me I totally
gave up on Dragon Ball super giving up I
just gave up on the sub cuz I just
cannot be bothered anymore with the
voice actors so I I will say that Goku
voice is distracting in the Japanese
though because he sounds like a whiny
girl you get used to it after a while
but yeah that's me I grew up with the
dubbed Dragon Ball Z and I thought that
dub was quite good especially freezes
creepy old woman white voice I thought
by the way sorry
not sure you asked me a while back what
do I think of kaki guru II whether or
not I think it's a letdown
I think of this show okay I keep
watching it though it's like one of
those show it's like I don't know what
is this is I don't know what's happening
and yet I keep watching it
every week so I guess it's a guilty
pleasure like I don't know if I'm
watching it for the training record I
don't know what's gonna happen next and
I'm just like what crazy [ __ ] is gonna
happen in this episode but I keep
watching it so I don't hate it so I
can't say it's a huge disappointment so
you mean you've met the guy with the eye
patch now I know yeah yeah yeah don't
know what the hell's going down there no
idea I mean like yes she was literally
masturbating herself with a gun and I
mean I know gonna stall she was
literally doing that again I'm still
watching it I don't know oh you watch
his fascination classroom remember the
guy that was eating soup with a gun oh
god yeah how do you eat soup with a gun
well he wasn't doing a very good job oh
you took out our boss we don't care
anymore so it's cool they beat em in
like five seconds stuff like spicy
juices up their nose and that was it
yeah that's that's interesting enemy
this kind of pokes fun at conventions
and cliches it's definitely a like
over-the-top sort of comedy anime that
works for some reasons works well also
has a hot Serbian girl as a character so
for that reason alone I have to like it
who are we talking about miss yellowish
oh the [ __ ] sensei
right hey I don't appreciate that racist
joke man yeah that was her name
that wasn't her actual name you should
make it racist jokes against Serbs what
do you not yeah no but yeah she's great
she's great and hot she is
yeah yeah she looks like she'd be the
thumbnail of one of your videos recon
I would put it as the thumbnail for this
video but that anime is not of this
appointment okay no oh
future disappointments I can't imagine
code geass three to be as good as the
ending of Code Geass r2 that's a good
point we'll see it all depends it all
depends if they were planning on
continuing the story the whole time so
it's not just gonna be an [ __ ] if
they were planning but then they ran out
of the budget and they wouldn't produce
them anymore like we were told and they
had a story in mind the whole time it
could be good that'd be s not true
that's so not true even if they left
little clues that left the fans you know
arguing is he alive is he dead whatever
I mean they couldn't have been expecting
to make a second season for ten years
and not had the money sunrise pulled out
so many Gundam crap like what's it
called that Ryu nakorn you want it yeah
that was terrible how long was it 25
episodes 50 episodes I don't know he
didn't even get through it out yeah hey
it's not like they had no money to
continue it and Code Geass made them the
most money they've made from all anime
made them more than I think the whole
Gintama made them no but it made it
after the fact not as it was airing Code
Geass kept getting rescheduled and
having issues with production and again
have the budget that they wanted so yeah
while it was airing it wasn't as big a
success or they didn't think it would be
so they did have it well in the end it
was and I think that it wasn't while it
was airing because of all the other
things that was everything else was
going on at that point mm but from 2006
to 2008 it was like a really high time
for anime a lot of great stuff came out
then well Gurren Lagann did so I have to
agree Gurren Lagann did and Baccano did
no another season am I right or am i
right
baka no does not need another season
what do you mean didn't end in a
satisfying way
well and that's because it did end in a
satisfying way and then there was a
three Episode OVA that just sort of
didn't end up anywhere but it was the
moat it was the best storytelling I've
seen an anime in Baccano well if it's
one of those where it has a lot of it's
like a huge cast and yet they do an
effective job of actually telling the
story and they tell it three timelines
all at the same time jumping back and
forth and everything sort of matches up
together at the end I don't know I
really would not touch an anime like
that
well like I would definitely agree with
you durarara tries to do the same thing
same creators but doesn't succeed
because for me to out on the pacing was
off a lot of the times they're focusing
on the characters we don't really care
about instead of the cool characters so
to me do not almost like a bad failed
version of Balkan I think that they
appeared it was fun favorite part of the
Ratana my favorite part is when the to
decouple from the immortal come from
baku know that's what wanted to name one
of the names again obvi second Meera
those guys are awesome yeah that was my
favorite part
[Music]
yeah I love those those things they're
called crossovers yeah done tastefully
like kind of like little Easter eggs
yeah for never next season I don't know
if you guys will watch an anime called
black clover which is being animated by
studio parrot no I want come on Sol no I
won't watch it by node a is popular and
lots of people looking forward to it but
yeah I'll definitely try it but however
it is made by it's being animated by a
studio which we all don't like so it can
either go two ways it can be good or the
studio itself can [ __ ] it up so I really
don't know I mean - two series that I
think with disappointing as well was a
my whole sense a nojima cuz it didn't
follow the manga again it just went the
whole harem plot and then there's
out nor 0aa I don't know I think that
also that they got my favorite writer
again or a Butchie to write the first
episode and to write the basic idea for
and premise for the story and he was
charging a lot of money and they got rid
of him after like episode 1 or 2 and
they got someone else and then a fell
apart yeah I mean for me it was just
like the main character I didn't get him
anyway because there was no reason for
him to be so stoic when he's got a
perfectly normal functioning sister then
with the end of season 1 with all those
people that are apparently dead they all
live yeah I mean that's the anime we're
getting shot in the head
well I was shot dead in that one spot
that the brain doesn't do anything so I
was totally okay now I just have a
shouting gun yeah that's it
I'll no 0 I'm on slain side by the way
he's the best character okay because
right in the beginning slain left smart
the Martians and he was gonna join them
and he saved the Earthlings and inaho is
like yo slain you saved yo dude I don't
know who you are you saved us that's
amazing and he says yes I'm gonna help
you infiltrate the Martians ship I know
their whole blueprints well how do you
know their whole blueprints well I'm a
Martian you're a Martian and just shot
him down what are you joking
this was the friendship that was gonna
pull the anime forward but no he just
shot him down and he became rivals and
for no reason and that's where the anime
just I started not caring by the way a
peerless opinion the names themselves
after a villain from Cowboy Bebop
what villain from Cali babe I didn't
catch that
Pierrot laughs ooh that Pierrot is crazy
in French yeah but he is that is an
actual villain in cowboy bebop whoo-hoo
epic foreshadowing yeah number two
series I didn't like the anime adaption
of one being poopa because it was just
recklessly done show episodes Cooper P
pupil
oh sure episode horror four minutes and
horror yeah you couldn't even get
anything out of that so it's a waste of
time intro sequence people explode
ending sequence yeah basically I knew it
was ridiculous and then there's a man
and so that is like it's really graphic
in places and like a lot longer
obviously but a lot of it was toned down
for the anime and then you know the
whole made up ending so characters get
destroyed in the process and yeah yeah
well what were you expecting
how could you expect anything from that
anyways I mean the whole premise of the
show was just about the Big Brother
wanting to [ __ ] his little sister
obviously yeah but that was pretty much
given away in episode 1 I don't know if
you remember but after the first episode
came out I was like oh man and I made a
sarcastic trailer on the first episode
and I was spot-on with all my
predictions for the whole series like
was it or emo mark I liked or emo for
the actual ending you should have gone
with Karen echo but then again you know
best girl never wins that's the rule
it's following in reesy ro also best
girl never wins right adam ak why you
try to why he try to piss me off girl
Amelia best girl Amelia okay roll you're
all on a rank of fate is next let's go
Mimi embrace know for sure
Amelia buzzer yeah moving on Oh so who's
going Nisekoi Nisekoi Mexico oh my god
yeah news
he's like a best girl Oh God is so hard
because there's some really good girls
cyber because freedom there's uh no
terror there's mommy
no and no no yeah three gone no really I
have to say best girl is sugu me better
name yeah that's it that's the one
Sookie me this one I like her the best
the black tiger or whatever yeah yeah
that's how yeah but she only got like
two episodes of screen time so I mean
there was no there was never really a
question so for me the fight was honor
there ng togi between those two and and
I'd have to say cheeto gay wins hands
down why don't why why why tsundere
beats whatever on it there is exactly
yeah no but so know what I hate I hate
the shy stalker in the background that's
too embarrassed to say everything and
it's his crush all along but childhood
friends so he can't say anything she
follows him everywhere really she tries
that it's true you know guys you know
what an ox or green it's time to wrap
things up come on you know what [ __ ] is
getting crazy
I suppose say the biggest disappointment
of all time in enemy is there not being
a second season of Keijo right now okay
well it's becoming a national sword
somewhere hopefully I'm making a real
sport they're trying to do it in
Portugal good people let's do it up baby
now the biggest disappointment and
absolute insult to animation worldwide
is ninja Slayer oh wow I dare you what's
that [ __ ] yeah that was that was pretty
unbearable yeah that was terrible I
watched all of about five minutes and
was it was it I can't I can't go watch
my sarcastic trailer on I think was
burrowed oh I compared ninjas from there
to ninjas from ninja Slayer I did watch
it's not the abridge so what was the
enemy that you were talking about that
that has like oh oh yes yes four point
something on my animation yeah four
point six yeah you got a 4.6 is yes did
any of you watch vampire homes no home
is law well that was a pretty horrible
okay but if you haven't watched it
whatever okay and big let downs we're
gonna have to make this kill a kill
video one day Hanna Mac well killer
killed debate obviously kill kill is not
a letdown you are wrong like kill kill
is not see this is this is same problem
with the nuts and sold both of them in
general are quite intelligent
individuals but like with these guys
generally I agree but then there are
certain things like thinking RAM is best
girl and saying things like kill a kill
is not awesome that just gives me pause
just gives me pause I hate you I'm not
saying you're an intelligent we just
some different opinions on so much stuff
that I'm not surprised when we disagree
whereas with these guys most of the time
we agree and then they had there's these
little things that were like what are
you thinking well I know Eureka Seven
yeah what what why why would anyone like
that alright I mean I I had no pop like
your your problem is like you don't like
crybaby emcees
and and the pacing you say yeah you say
the pacing but I know I didn't find a
problem with that patient it seemed to
be steady you know and then after when
he left the whole reason of him
leaving like from a story standpoint is
to help do the world-building in drier
characters you know the characters the
uh-oh well start that disease that they
get the little like they're in a coma
and stuff you know so it was just
building up the world more and then
eventually he comes back and then we're
back on all fighting again at first
inside the ship while he's you know
locked up and stuff and then later on
when actually like dealing with actual
like the empire and stuff so I mean for
me it was right for me I was alright now
they have probably no no I know is that
crazy girl from the evil side his best
girl the pink haired one with like the
pink area yeah yeah okay yeah I don't
remember her name or anything but Oh
karma burning alright guys I think it's
time to wrap things up we were all
disappointed hugely on this stream by
each other's points of view and by the
anime disappointments as well thank you
everyone for coming in the chat let
don't forget to leave in the comments
once the video is uploaded some ideas
for future topics I'd love to get your
ideas and we if we like it it might
become a next topic for a cafe I predict
that the thumbnail for this video once I
put a thumb it will trigger the [ __ ] out
of recon on my guns
see also also let me go through the
peeps who are here and kind of have them
introduce themselves who they are what
they do let's go to knocks hello
Nux Taku anime youtuber I make videos
about sarcastic facts and sarcastic
trailers in a way that I can insult
things without people getting that
triggered cuz they know it's all sarcasm
and they won't be too upset at me I also
do analysis and critique and my opinions
are right right weak on the content
knocks but people's will get triggered
don't fool yourself well that is part of
the point I must say waiting for your
alo video
and I'm not I want to knock this channel
and recons channel in the description so
maka does not challenge yet but
hopefully soon soul hi
yes hello everyone it's me so Viceroy on
Animax discord anime I'll post this code
and then I'm also into drawing dojin's
and stuff and trying to work on a visual
novel at the moment but most importantly
within the next month or so I should
have my YouTube channel up and going and
it's gonna cover content of manga and
anime in my suggestion for the channel
name is hentai bankai that sounds good
actually you go there with the globe
between his legs and if we like banged
you go there holding his big sword but
the sword is pixelated yeah any rate and
going to recon please don't do the whole
inhaling thing it's really annoying
what up dis recon I do them the live
reactions and toptenz a MV quality top
tens you can you know me as ricardo pico
havoc no pico subscribe to my channel
and [ __ ] those guys and ya know koreans
challenge all right Thank You recon
thank you guys for being here
ya know everybody rang cafe going strong
be sure to leave a like if you liked
these livestreams be sure to join our
discord server if you want to talk on a
daily basis get an American Dacians
discuss anime series get anime news all
that stuff link in the description and
until next time see us bass cowboys I
love you on bang
you